first of all i'm a firm believer that
dads are super important in children's
lives and i think that the way that
you're a superhero as a dad is that
you're present right that you're present
you're bringing something unique to the
table that a mom can't bring i'm a very
big believer in a mom and a dad in a
home and the importance of that because
women and men are fundamentally
different we each bring different things
to the table and the child learns very
different lessons from each of us even
if you look at my kid
goes and plays soccer
i'm there my husband's there we're there
together at every single soccer game for
this little guy he loves it he looks for
mom he looks for dad he looks at us for
different things i'm always running
after him making sure he's got his water
making sure he's not too hot putting the
hat on
jeremy's there cheering him down come on
you go get that goal you get it's just
so different but it's so so important to
be present so and i think tate is going
to change his mind about this when he
becomes a dad i think so
i'll uh i've done when i was uh when i
was doing work with when pat campbell
was still alive i used to uh we used to
have these conversations about like
parenting like how important usually it
was like around like father's day
yeah right because everybody hates their
dad like everyone like he was a son of a
[ __ ] i don't ever want to be like him
you know and it's it's like father's day
is just like the uh the the messages
always do better right that's all it
comes down to and the reason why that's
popular right now is because we have
this uh notion that guys like men like
fathers in general are either homer
simpson or they're the abusive guy who
left mom he was he was the guy you got
two choices really you've got the the
doofy dad
or who tells dad jokes and you know
farts now and then or else you've got
the guy who's like the borderline abuser
i never want to be like my dad you know
or so or why do we say that like
strippers have daddy issues right that's
so it's always this sort of negative
connotation world war and thinking about
them you know fathers and this really
kind of harkens back to how we've kind
of destroyed masculinity in general um
or confused it and as a result we've
demonized like men
in general but we demonize fathers in
specific here because what we've done is
we've made fathers superfluous
so when we talk about like um you know
we need more we need fathers in the
household we need that's great but they
don't really get into specifics about it
they never wanted to well he just him
being there is all that's really
necessary in some cases that might be
true however you can't tell guys to man
up after generations of telling them to
man down so when we when we look at
women like say on on mother's day we
think oh they're superheroes they can do
anything
i never needed a dad my mom took care of
it for me she was just as much of a man
she could do anything she's this
androgynous thing she's she's the best
of bull of masculinity and femininity
and that's simply a false statement
because what it's meant to do is to keep
you know kids in single parent homes is
what it's meant to do however when we
when that kid
is into drugs when that kid is a
criminal when that kid gets into uh is
suicidal then we say where's dad when
that kid becomes a school shooter
where's dad that's the responsibility
but you take away his authority because
he's superfluous up until the point
where the kid acts out and he does
something that has a criminal act and
now we want to know where the where the
guys f where this kid's father is
because he's not living up to the
expectations that we think he ought to
have so that's one aspect of it and i do
understand that
guys need to be in the household they
need to be fathers they need to be i
would also argue this is there's
probably a lot more fathers in the
household doing a lot more than anyone
wants to give them credit for now
because as i said it's it's easier to
create [ __ ] than it is to refute
[ __ ] and i can also show you like
say in the black community there are a
lot more fathers that are involved with
their kids right now they're just not
married to the mothers they're still
involved they still want to have their
kids they want to have custody they want
to be involved in their kids lives but
because they're not married we say
they're absent because they're not
married to the mother no they're still
the father but because what the criteria
is based on marriage then we say oh well
it's a single-parent household and
statistically speaking if that's the
definition they're correct so it doesn't
necessarily mean involvement doesn't
necessarily mean marriage but we i would
hope it would because you want to have
that sort of you know mom is there to
provide the uh conventional feminine
model the the model on which that kid
understands femininity and masculinity
that conventional model is provided by
the the father that is is present in
that household now that's what i get
into in my third book which is positive
masculinity i talk i go into great
detail and parenting in there because
that's one of the questions that's
thrown at me like when should my kids
read the rational mail roll i don't want
them to fall into the same pitfalls that
i did well i wrote a book about that so
that you know guys would would have
something to sort of like you know to go
a road map at the at the very least to
go by now i'm gonna throw everything
under the bus now okay here we go
this is i think this is from claire
lehman but she was doing this
dissertation okay how to be a parent in
2017 okay well in modern times make sure
your child's academic emotional
psychological mental spiritual physical
nutritional and so
social needs are met while being careful
not to over stimulate under stimulate
improperly medicate helicopter or
neglect them in a screen free processed
foods free gmo free negative energy free
plastic free body positive socially
conscious egalitarian but also
authoritative
nurturing but fostering independence
gentle but not overly permissive uh
pesticide-free two-story
multi-multi-lingual home preferably in a
cul-de-sac with a backyard and 1.5
siblings spaced at least two years apart
for proper development also don't forget
the coconut oil okay okay how do you do
that organically
coconut oil
how to be a parent how to be a parent
and literally every other generation
feed them sometimes
that's what really what he's kind of
coming back to is like we're we're over
in some cases we're over parenting so
you have to take that in consideration
as well right if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
you